[Musique]
messieurs bonsoir seront pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle thinker view vont
soit dans le cadre de notre envie de
savoir un peu plus sur ce qui se passe
sur la populaire pollution pardon et de
ses répercussions sur la pollution on va
on va commencer par gilles dixsaut
bonjour gilles quand je vois ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succinctement kit
vous qu'est-ce qu'on en fait dans la vie
je suis médecin actuellement médecins
hospitaliers présager fait pas la plus
grande partie de ma carrière en tant le
poids de 5 santé publique notamment
ministère de la santé et j'ai aussi une
activité associative dans le cadre de la
fondation du souffle et le comité d'île
de france contre les maladies
respiratoires
vous avez été aussi conseiller spécial
du ministère de la santé que ça j'ai été
conseiller scientifique au ministère de
la santé à une époque serge serge orru
qui êtes vous serge orru je suis choisi
en mètre 67 je suis conseiller auprès de
la maire de paris je fus directeur
général du wwf et organisateur du
célèbre festival du vent à calvi de 1992
à 2004 aux
nicolas bay ont
qui êtes-vous donc je suis ingénieur
conseil énergie et transport
par ailleurs dans l'activité associative
je suis du conseil scientifique de l'eau
angie respire et membres d econoclaste
on va repartir sur gilles gilles il ya
combien de temps en france dus à la
pollution atmosphérique atmos ioniques
ça dépend comment les comptes parce que
chacun à sa façon de les compter et donc
on a des résultats qui vont
dire et de 0 à 100 milles chaque année
ce mais les
décomptes qui sont les plus crédibles
sont ceux qui ont été réalisés par santé
publique france
sur la base d'une comparaison
de nif de différents niveaux de
pollution
avec mise en face d'un nombre de décès
probable alors bien entendu ce sont des
ordres de grandeur alors d'après ces
résultats il est dit que
environ 48 mille décès prématurés par an
seraient dus à la pollution par
rapport à une pollution nul anthropique
anthropique nul c'est un rêve créée par
les hommes si on avait une pollution
zéro ce qui est totalement illusoire et
réalisable on aurait 48 mille décès
prématuré de moins si on se fixer à la
hauteur des recommandations de l oms on
aurait un excellent de décès qui
seraient de l'ordre de 16 mille décès
par an bien sûr ce sont toujours des
ordres de grandeur et on n'est pas à
quelques unités près et par contre si on
se fixe sur les niveaux de pollution qui
sont recommandées par l'europe on aurait
quasiment aucun gain de en terme de
mortalité alors ces calculs ont été
réalisés à partir des paies des
particules pm2 5
considéré comme un marqueur globale de
la pollution maintenant si on veut
considérer chacun des marqueurs
individuellement c'est à dire le dioxyde
d azote par exemple les pm2 5 les pme 01
va on arriverait sans doute à des
calculs qui sont des calculs
plus donnant des effectifs plus
importants mais comme on a ce qu'on
appelle des effets cocktail c'est à dire
que les polluants entre eux
non seulement la terra jce mais en plus
donne des effets qui sont cumulatifs et
il est très difficile en termes
d'épidémiologie de faire la part de ski
et chacun des polluants et de ski et la
part de l'effet cocktail de ces
polluants en termes à la fois de
morbidité et de mortalité est ce que est
ce que vous avez identifié
un paramètre là on va dire létale selon
la classe sociale est-ce qu'il ya plus
ou moins de morges et les pauvres qui
habitent à côté du périphérique ou
est-ce qu'il ya plus de morts dans les
gens qui habitent sur le moteur à la sto
de paris le
il ya un effet effectivement du niveau
d'exposition à la pollution sur la
morbidité et la mortalité on sait que
certains arrondissements notamment de
paris le plus tôt le nord-est de paris
on a un risque lié à la pollution qui
est manifestement plus à l'est mais
c'est lié au fait que dans ces
arrondissements on a une pollution qui
est plutôt plus élevé que dans d'autres
par contre dans le 8e arrondissement par
exemple où on a aussi un niveau de
pollution élevée on n'a pas réellement
une surmortalité ou une sur mobilité
parce que on a je dirais une population
qui est manifestement un peu plus aisés
et qui a aussi les moyens d'aller voir
ailleurs et pas passer son temps
toujours au même endroit donc ça c'est
aussi un phénomène qui est un phénomène
de liés aux déplacements des gens
combien de temps ils passent chacun dans
tel ou tel endroit ça a été montré
récemment au canada dans une étude qui a
montré que la pollution a un effet sur
les maladies neurodégénératives
c'est-à-dire notamment les démences mais
que cet effet est d'autant plus
important que les gens bougent peu et
qu' ils sont à proximité des grands axes
de circulation donc la proximité des
grands axes de circulation est un
facteur de risque en terme de maladies
neurodégénératives mais si les personnes
se déplacent et elle ne passe pas tout
leur temps même endroit le risque plutôt
plus faible parce que ils vont respirer
un meilleur ailleurs c'est un peu comme
une radiation c'est un peu comme les
radiations oui si on veut serge qu'est
ce que fait la ville de la mairie de
paris pour protéger ses concitoyens
bien on l'a eue depuis 2001
même jacques chirac avait entamé une
action mais mme tiberi a entamé une
action jacques chirac a inventé les
potelets et les potelets mes potes
l'esquissé les poteaux qui empêchent les
voitures de se garer sur les trottoirs
monsieur tiberi a
lancé le premier coup le couloir de bus
bertrand delanoë avec anne hidalgo et
bien il ya eu les couloirs de bus à
grande échelle
vélib autolib et il ya une vraie
véritable action en faveur du transport
public et puis il
décrire une réalité puisque la mobilité
c'est quelque chose c'est là le
apparaître comme la liberté pour tout le
monde or là qu'est ce que c'est paris
paris ses 102 kilomètres carrés c'est la
cinquième
ville dans le monde au niveau de la
densité urbaine c'est la première en
europe
la cinquième devant nous il ya shanghai
102 kilomètres carrés on est dans le
périph et à l'intérieur du périphérique
avant c'était les fortifications donc
parié est enserrée dans ce périphérique
de plus de deux millions deux cent mille
habitants
tous les jours deux millions de
franciliens rentrer dans paris un sur
trois en voiture un parisien sur dix
utilise sa voiture donc c'est ce qu'il
faut faire ce que nous avons commencé à
faire bien sûr les vous avez là
l'ouverture aux piétons
l'utilisation des voies sur berges se
rappelle que les voies sur berge et 3,3
km dont plus de 1 km de tunnel donc là
on a offert à la population un havre de
paix c'est pas c'est pas les trois
kilomètres 302
des berges de seine rive droite qui
provoque la thrombose dans paris
aujourd'hui vous avez
comme cette densité elle était
extrêmement forte vous avez des travaux
du tramway porte d'asnières qui se
termineront en fin 2018 devant de 2018
vous avez des travaux très importants
porte maillot et raté p et ça ça
thrombose paris dd qui a des travaux
pour le chauffage urbain vous provoquez
des immobilisations des blocages
à paris vous avez le plus grand
métropolitain du monde le métro on peut
le critiquer mais c'est le plus grand la
qualité de l'air dans le métro et
comment elle peut bonne ce n'est pas
bonne acuité dans le métro et il faut
l'améliorer pourquoi n'at il pas bonne
parce que vous avez ce que depuis ce que
je disais j'ai le tout à l'heure et les
particules fines les particules fines
les pm2 5
dans la section dans votre diamètre de
votre cheveu jose par les lumières vous
mettez 30 pm 2,5 à peu près
confirmé donc 30 vous imaginez quand le
quand on respire cela cpm de sacs ou cpm
0 1 ça va directement dans tout notre
organisme et dans tous nos organes bien
sûr ça provoque des maladies
respiratoires et de maladies
cardiovasculaires et puis alzheimer
parkinson aujourd'hui il ya des études
américaines qui démontre qu'il y a un
impacte donc mais comme dans le métro on
n'y reste pas longtemps c'est
moins nocif que lorsque vous êtes en
surface que ce qui prouve sa pardon
qu'est ce qui prouve là là là - nocivité
de la durée votre lorsque je prends le
métro le matin à pigalle pour haley
l'hôtel de ville j'ai vingt minutes j'ai
vingt minutes je ressors donc par contre
les travailleurs du métro ce doit être
un vrai sujet vous avez 300 bouches de
métro aujourd'hui à paris 300 bouche de
métro qui expulse un air pollué pollué
par la limaille de fer par la poussière
des du freinage savait que les
microparticules provoqué par
parler le freinage qui existe pour les
rames pour les motrices et de la ratp
mais problème les motrices de la sncf ou
pour les camions au point des voitures
je vous coupe gilles est ce que vous
avez vu un chiffre une étude passé sur
la sueur mentalité du personnel ratp un
trou je sais qu'il ya eu des études qui
ont été réalisées mais c'est très
compliqué à interpréter
parce que
le personnel passe du temps
effectivement dans des activités
professionnelles
au sein du métro et au sein des tunnels
du métro n'oubliez pas que la nuit il ya
des gens qui font l'entretien des voies
l'entretien des des tunnels mais aussi
ils vont passer une partie de leur temps
une grande partie de leur temps à
l'extérieur et aussi chez eux donc
quelle est la part qui revient à cette
exposition à la pollution du métro et
puis les les professions ne sont pas les
mêmes entre les gens qui travaillent sur
les voies et les gens qui travaillent
par exemple dans des dans des guichets
les niveaux d'exposition sont pas les
mêmes choses aussi ce qu'il faut
comprendre en compte ces câbles le type
la nature des polluants n'est pas la
même que les polluants qui sont issus
par exemple du trafic du trafic routier
ce sont ce sont des comme le disait
serge des particules des micro
particules métalliques et des particules
inorganiques c'est à dire de la
poussière qui est lié
qui est soulevée lors du passage des
trains sur le ballast et ce n'est pas la
même chose que les particules
lié au trafic qui sont des particules
qui contiennent des composés organiques
on va poser une colle à serge et
revenir 300 bouche de métro donc ex plus
un air
qui si jamais on peut être viciée
il est sourd mais 300 bouches de métro
il faut aussi que ces 300 bouche de
métro depuis cette filtrer parce que
c'est air vicié va à l'extérieur
lorsque je sais pas si vous avez vu
devant la place blanche et au moulin
rouge devant le moulin rouge et il ya
une poule terre où tous les touristes
aiment à jouer les marilyn monroe parce
que cette terre tu te laisses des fins
non non non non j'habite là bas je peux
vous dire c'est pas des sdf qui sont là
sur les bouches de métro en tout cas pas
je parle de plaques blanches donc et il
aime faire au marilyn monroe sauf que là
il respire un air qui n'est pas un mot
voilà donc la problématique de la
qualité de l'air serré sans
sélection parce qu'on vient de découvrir
ou parce que c'est l'industrialisation
qui la crise pour le main les deux mon
capitaine je vois le docteur nous faire
un petit signe de la tête
ça dépend ce qu'on appelle récent cirque
on est en action on veut parler du métro
on a commencé à s'intéresser à la
qualité de l'air dans le métro il ya 20
ans
oui c'est récent parce que le métro il a
plus de temps en temps mais on s'est pas
intéressée à la pollution par exemple le
mondre un clochard bon avec les terrils
non non non on s'est intéressé à la
pollution lorsqu'on a eu des vagues de
mortalité considérable lors de pollution
extrême notamment dans la vallée de la
meuse dans les années 30 et lors des
des smocks de londres en 1953 qui ont
fait quand même douze mille morts
combien de temps il faut pour déployer
un cancer et qu'elle donnerait
d'exposition il faut subir pour
développer un cancer selon patrimoine
génétique du patient
chief moyens il n'y a pas de réponse il
n'y a pas de réponse claire à cela parce
que vous pourrez développer un cancer
selon votre capital génétique puisqu'on
n'est pas du tout égaux devant la
maladie
vous pourrez très bien ne pas être
exposé à la pollution ne pas fumer faire
un cancer du poumon d'autant plus que
maintenant on a des des formes de cancer
du poumon qui sont
différentes des formes de cancer de
poumon pont d'observer il ya 30 40 ou 50
ans on peut penser que l'exposition à la
pollution moderne pourrait participer à
cette nouvelle forme de cancer mais on
peut pas faire des expérimentations sur
l'homme dans ce cadre là elle entend que
serge les politiques on fait comment
pour les conseillers face à ces menaces
est national moi ce que le coin c'est
qu'il faut qu'ils aient des indicateurs
forts
aujourd'hui à paris vous avez un
organisme qui fait un travail conséquent
qu'il appelle airparif mais il faut
remarquer qu'à faire pareil cas avec des
ingénieurs des gens ne sont plus de 90
ans d'une grande qualité ces hommes et
ces femmes pour la plupart ingénieurs
mais ils sont pris entre le marteau et
l'enclume
il faut savoir que la mairie d'issy les
moulineaux a supprimé les capteurs donc
plus de capteurs plus de policiers
pourquoi plus de capteurs plus de
pollution on casse le thermomètre voilà
vous avez les hauts-de-seine qui ont
supprimé la subvention
donc ils trient s'est sentie n'y
pas de nom à l'antenne donc
questions réponses
et santini qu'un suisse qui a enlevé la
subvention
d'enlever les capteurs 15e et capteur
wii pour les hauts-de-seine cela veut
dire donc donc c'est des organismes qui
dépendent à la fin des subsides à la
fois de l'état des collectivités
il faut une étude pour mesurer
l'observation et observer
les berges rive droite parce que vous
savez vous avez compris qu'aujourd'hui
les embouteillages la pollution c'est
anne hidalgo que les inventer
lorsqu'anna un embouteillage ajaccio
c'est anne hidalgo donc je ne retraités
donc non mais je je je je plaisante je
plaisante mais le
c'est pas anne hidalgo qui a inventé la
pollution et en région parisienne c'est
tout un ensemble je parlais tout à
l'heure des 102 kilomètres carrés de
paris vous avez une région ile de france
et cette région la pollution elle vienne
où elle peut venir l'épandage agricole
elle peut venir du tout le transport
routier diesel et essence
elle peut venir des feux de cheminée or
les feux de fait mis un avion ou sinon
les les feux de cheminée c'est
extrêmement polluant il faut dire ça
vient les poussières de frein
20% des microparticules en ville s'agir
de pneus eux deux qui étaient fiers de
ce train c'est très dans le sang et peut
faire des choix
je pourrais vous en parlais tout à
l'heure parce que en train de promouvoir
un système de récupérateur de poussière
de fret ou tout à l'heure donc cette
pollution cette pollution elle est
multiple est ce qu'il faut c'est donner
les moyens à airparif mais aujourd'hui
vous avez des capteurs d'air laser quoi
donner les moyens
combien combien
il faut donner des moyens est en tout
cas erp arif là ça ressemble à des
propositions incantatoire il faut donner
des moyens r paris et à d'autres parce
que vous savez très bien que aujourd'hui
mesurer la qualité de l'air
hier il y avait des capteurs d'air à
200000 euros et capteurs d'air qui pesé
qui pèsent les microparticules
aujourd'hui vous avez venue de corée de
chine des etats-unis des capteurs laser
qui coûte 150 200 euros donc
l'important c'est d'avoir les deux de
toute façon vous subissez l'oubli à
pouvoir mesurer
à partir du mois on connaîtra rue par
rue la pollution
réelle big data par exemple rue par rue
on pourra contrer pourquoi et là il ya
autant de pollution dans cette rue est
parce que c est ce que parce qu'il ya un
effet canyon parce que c'est
le temps qu'il en est ce que parce qu'il
ya une compagnie de crs qui stationnait
à 24 sur 24 et qui fait marcher ses
duels
est ce que c'est à cause de lui j'ai
raté paix qu'elle a
qui fonctionne à l'arrêt et c est ce que
c'est parce qu'il ya une station taxi on
pourra mesurer traquer et contrer
enrayer cette pollution or aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est il y a des il ya des
indications et par exemple est ce qu'on
pourra se retourner vers le politique en
disant écoute coup
parce que quand et quand c'est bon là
quand quand tu étais la mairie de paris
ma tête est censé faire des travaux pour
respirer correctement est-ce que grâce à
ces études là on va pouvoir se retourner
vers new political en disant voilà vous
avez pas fait correctement milliards et
les politiques et puis tu vas pas faire
il ya qu'à faut qu'on quand même là il
n'y a pas que les politiques dans la vie
il ya un mode industriel ce monde
industriel il a un impact
le politique
il est là cinq ans il en sait tant est
ce qu'il ya des connaissances tu parles
des pm 2,5 au politique au monde
politique aujourd'hui
l'ajout croûte et ya très peu de
politiques qui connaissent le sujet
étant dit les politiques aujourd'hui
l'association justement respire
aujourd'hui avec écologie sans frontière
et 30 30 personnes a mis un procès donc
à l'état justement pour non
réglementation de la qualité de l'air et
donc ça ça se passe en france pour
l'instant on est dans l'attenté d'une
date pour l'audience publique donc on a
déjà une trentaine de personnes et ce
type de chose se passe déjà dans
d'autres pays c'est ça qui avait
déclenché le scandale au japon dans les
années 90 c'était un procès c'est à dire
c'est qu'on avait aussi dû avec
l'amiante en angleterre aujourd'hui vous
avez des procès aussi qu'ils sont
attentifs contre l'état mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est ce qui se passe en
allemagne parce qu'en allemagne vous
avez donc une ong locale qui est assez
assez puissante et qui elle va attaquer
directement celle des collectivités
alors j'ai plus le nom j'ai plus le nom
mais elle va attaquer directement les
collectivités et donc on a une trentaine
de procès où finalement elle elle oblige
des collectivités à interdire soit le
diesel lors des jours de pollution soit
sur à hambourg il avait sur une artère
la halle l'artère la plus embouteillée
peut-être des champs-elysées interdire
la circulation des dizaines tout court
est aujourd'hui l'allemagne donc les
besoins politiques ont fait appel de la
décision pour que les disettes puisse
continuer continuer à rouler et c'est
donc aujourd'hui il ya clairement une
judiciarisation apposition pourquoi
parce qu'en fait vous avez l'union
européenne qui fixe des normes mais qui
ne punit jamais donc les seules
personnes qui peuvent finir c'est les
citoyens en se regroupant est à paris ce
sera pas un idéal go ce sera au niveau
de la préfecture de région qui a la
responsabilité de faire lapland de
protection d'environnement mais la seule
façon de faire respecter les normes
européennes qui ne sont pas respectées à
paris nous sommes hors la loi sur le
dioxyde d azote à des niveaux deux fois
supérieur par exemple par d'auteuil à la
norme européenne en europe et c'est pas
un cas de paris ou de anne hidalgo c'est
le cas dans toutes les capitales
d'europe sur le dioxyde d azote qui est
un polluant majoritairement émis par les
véhicules diesel et dont personne ne
parle en france on en parle partout en
europe mais pas en france on est
toujours au niveau des partis une et
bien on est particulier alors je vous
coupe je vous parle des charges et les
people
je vois le même tube oh bien sûr
agile c'est quoi le problème avec au
niveau de la santé au niveau du diesel
est tout de suite jean volume question à
serge pour le temps qu'ils puissent
réfléchir durant la réponse de gilles s
course est-ce que vous subissez des
pressions des industriels
est ce que par exemple il ya des petits
arrangements comme avec une certaine
marque de voiture qui a un peu triché
sur sa production de particules grâce à
un petit hack de deux puces au niveau du
contrôle technique de son pot
d'échappement c'est pas sur les
particules qui tricheraient sur leurs
notes exactement mercinois en prie donc
gilles le problème avec le diesel est
tout de suite derrière serge sur la
question de lobbying on parle du
problème avec le diesel mais ya pas que
le problème avec le diesel je vais
prendre un exemple tout simple les
véhicules essence à injection directe
des plus modernes sur ceux qui
produisent le plus de particules ils
produisent milly sont autorisées à
produire 6000 milliards de particules au
crible au kilomètre soit dix fois plus
que les véhicules diesel et des
particules de zéro 0,1 micron qui
pénètre le plus celle qui peut être bien
enfin qui est aussi qui pour une grande
partie s'arrête au niveau du nez et du
nez elle passe directement dans la
circulation et dans le cerveau ce sont d
un système lymphatique ou pas ça passe
dans tout le système toute la
circulation
parce que c'est ça traverse les cellules
c'est parti particules de taille
nanométrique et la paroisse de la
cellule qui s'appelle
la paroisse de la cellule
ça dépend ce qu'on est d'accord
c'est ce sont les phénomènes des
phénomènes dits de pin aussitôt c'est
traverse la paroi cellulaire et ces
particules qu'on qui sont émises par les
moteurs essences les plus modernes on
sait très bien qu'on n'a pas de moyens
réellement efficace de les diminuer en
diminuer le nombre on peut diminuer la
masse mais diminuer la masse n'a pas un
intérêt en termes d'effets sur la santé
puisque ce qui compte en termes de
particules c'est le nombre de particules
et la surface développée des particules
qui est d'autant plus importante que les
particules sont plus son petit est ce
que c'est un intérêt politique de dire
que le pollution baisse parce que bien
sûr bien sûr c'est évident qu avec les
pesticides nombre et c'est un point
c'est bien sûr parce qu'on mesure la
masse des particules on sait qu'un
filtre à part à un filtre à particules
va vous diminuez 2 99% la masse de
particules mais ce qu'on oublie de vous
dire c'est que s'il m'aime filtre à
particules il divise le diamètre moyen
des particules d'un facteur 10 tu peux
faire mon filtre à particules la surface
développée des particules elle sera
égale donc la réactivité des particules
ce ryan et le nombre de particules sera
multipliée par dix donc on nous dit
c'est très bien avec des filtres à
particules on a divisé par 100 la masse
des particules émises monade divisée
enfin on a diminué surtout les gros les
ce qu'on appelle les agrégats de
particules c'est à dire les les
assemblages de particules qui font qu'un
diesel fume et
par contre on a en diminuant de ses
agrégats on ne permet plus aux
particules élémentaires qui ont un
diamètre de 100 nanomètres de s'agréger
dessus donc on va les laisser libres ces
particules donc tout le monde est
content en disant on à diminuer la
pollution particulaire la facture sans
moi je réponds non on a augmenté la
pollution particulaire d'un facteur 10
en termes de nombre serge
au début du mandat d'un hugo les
notoriété publique qu'un grand
constructeur automobile dont je ne
citerai pas le nom dans le bureau de la
mer la menace est quel type de menaces
en disant que si elle continuait sa
politique soit disant anti voiture
elle serait pareil
comment ça le serait pas réussir que
vous êtes en train de me dire qu'un
consortium de vendeurs d'automobiles est
capable de destituer le peuple de sa
mairesse ou demain vous savez très bien
que si des constructeurs autonomie dont
étaient capables de tricher je rappelle
quand même que la triche a été
découverte par une association pro
voitures produisent à eux d'ailleurs qui
simplement est à la société américaine
et qui a découvert qu'il y avait un
décalage entre ce que les constructeurs
automobiles à notre
bien sûr
notamment
là c'est encore une fois le voyait
tricher mais l'ensemble des
constructeurs automobiles on trie c'est
donc partir du moment où vous avez des
industriels qui trichent
lorsque vous avez et des politiques il
n'y a pas que anne hidalgo le maire de
londres à une pause et d'une position
extrêmement offensive si vous avez face
à vous que quelqu'un moi je suis pas
anti voiture moi mon rêve à 16 ans
étaient des champions du monde de
formule 1 j'ai jamais compris personne
n'est parfait je n'ai jamais compris
pourquoi
je ne toujours faire du kart et j'aime
la vitesse en ski c'est des rats mais je
n'ai jamais compris pourquoi alors qu'il
ya des ingénieurs automobiles français
mons qualité les ingénieurs de la
formulation d'une immense qualité
pourquoi on n'a pas mis leur ingéniosité
pour réduire l'empreinte écologique de
l'automobile chute était possible oui à
quel prix à quel prix si vous comptez le
prix de la santé aujourd'hui impacter
sur l'ensemble des populations ça coûte
des milliards et des milliards après
tout on tient compte
de milliards c'est ça jeudi entre 1 et 2
milliards alors ce que dit le sénat ses
103 milliards d'euros par an que coûte
la pollution atmosphérique nous le
travail qu'on avait fait c'était de
dévaluer à minima je vous expliquer
pourquoi minima le coût de la pollution
atmosphérique pour les bus pour
l'assurance maladie et uniquement sur
les maladies respiratoires
attribuables à la pollution
atmosphérique et le calcul que nous
avions fait montré que la pollution
atmosphérique
ajoutait chaque année aux dépenses de
santé puisqu'on avait considéré que les
cas incidence est à dire les nouveaux
cas de l'année et pas les cap caval ans
c'est à dire l'écart existant dans la
population c'est ces cas incidents
amener chaque année un surcoût pour
l'assurance maladie de 1 à 2 milliards
d'euros mais ces cas incidents il
ne meurt pas tout de suite ils vont
vivre pendant
la semaine les asthmatiques vont vivre
trente ans ou 40 ans de plus voire plus
et donc ce sont des milliards qui
s'ajoutent chaque année aux dépenses
d'assurance maladie
colin moi ce que ce qui me choque en
fait dans cette affaire c'est que
finalement en france a pas à la mairie
de paris anne hidalgo qui apprend une
mesure qui n'est pas finalement contre
le disent elle puisque avoue à long
terme c'est de dire on enlève les
voitures diesel et essence donc d'abord
le diesel parce que c'est ce qui
polluent le plus et puis après 10 ans en
2030 ça c'est ce qui se passe et ce qui
va se passer dans le monde entier oslo
commence à le faire oxford le fait en
2020 sur les essences et diesels en même
temps et donc ça c'est la tendance s'est
déjà intelligent sur la partie la
pollution parce que c'est un phénomène
concentré et locales et ce sera aussi
intelligent sur la partie énergie parce
qu'on va manquer on sera content rassure
du pétrole et donc il va falloir se
passer du visage du pétrole dont on peut
le plus se passer et c'est
vraisemblablement en ville puisqu'il ya
un certain nombre d'alternatives et qui
existe moi ce qui me choque
personnellement c'est que récemment hier
on a annoncé edouard philippe on va
baisser la vitesse de 90 à 80 km/heure
effectivement quand vous baisser la
vitesse de 80 90 et c'est l'ancien
ingénieur crash qui parle vous baisser
de 10% mais vous avez un gain de 20% sur
la mortalité donc c'est et c'est là où
les gens se tue en voiture donc c'est
bien on va pouvoir faire quelques
centaines
deux morts - mais la pollution
atmosphérique le nombre de cancers
aujourd'hui quand on parle de mort de
cancer et pollution je crois que lors de
vendeurs c'est à peu près 3000 c'est le
même ordre de grandeur que
l'accidentologie sur route ce mot si je
crois que c'est 3512 3500 par an et donc
mais on en parle beaucoup moins on n'a
pas toutes ces mesures là je voyais
aussi récemment la politique sur les
vaccins on avait trois quatre cinq morts
par je suis plus qu'elle je sais plus
quelle maladie on rend tous les vaccins
obligatoires mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
c'est 3000 morts deux cancers
qu'est ce qu'on fait de ces quelques
dizaines de milliers morts prématurées
aujourd'hui le ministère compétent c'est
vrai que le ministère de la santé que
fellini femmes affrontés sur la
pollution aujourd'hui
serge
fortin sont connus c'est quand même ce
cas l'incroyable en revenant à cette
émission je me disais qu'elle a quand
même incroyable comment comment se
fait-il que ce que nous ce sujet soirée
sans
moi je suis un activiste
écolo je me bats depuis 40 ans sur ce
sujet là gilles depuis longtemps avant
tu commences ta blague c'est quoi le
truc le plus chaud plus risqué que t'es
fait dans ta carrière d'activistes ce
que j'ai fait je te le dirais pas
parentèle non et je peux déjà te dire
après tu es assez mal
il continue donc pourquoi ces récents
donc intéressant parce que soudain il ya
une relation avec la santé la voiture
c'est
le message et la mobilité la voiture
c'est la liberté aller d'un point
c'est ce qu'on avait dans la tête des
gens n'est pas mon point de vue
l'image publicitaire c'est la liberté
et puis il ya des zones où il ya des
zones si je suis en corse si ma femme et
moi et mes enfants nous sommes chez nous
soudas en corse il faut quatre voitures
au fin fond de l'auvergne il faut quatre
voitures et cetera et cetera donc il
il ya des fois des besoins importants et
pourquoi on n'a pas perçu des voitures
non polluantes
pourquoi on n'a pas conçu une mobilité
non polluants la question qu'il faut se
poser c'est le faire c'est quoi des
voitures la voiture à quoi air comprimé
non content quand on avait travaillé sur
la loi sur l'air utilisation rationnelle
de l'énergie de 96 on avait fait faire
des on a fait des études sur la
pollution est liée aux différents types
de motorisations et ce qui était apparu
très clairement c'était que les
véhicules les moins polluants sont les
véhicules à gaza des moteurs les mains
poulains sont les véhicules à gaz et on
nous a dit à l'époque en france on n'en
veut pas et ce n'est pas seulement se
sont pas seulement les industriels qui
nous ont dit ça ce sont aussi des
administrations pour des raisons qui
sont
je dirais obscures mais que nous savons
parfaitement qu'il bat ce sont des
collusions entre des administrations
des corps des grands corps de l'état
des choses des choses comme ça pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce que ce qui s'est fait en
par exemple en corée du sud les coptes
du constructeur automobile de corée du
sud on me disait totalement sur le sur
les moteurs à gaz le les constructeurs
japonais on misait sur les sur les
hybrides et en france on pour des
raisons
techniques archaïques on a misé sur le
diesel parce qu'il fallait défendre
médias qui dodelinent de la tête
pour laquelle on a mis en avant le
diesel en fait c'était le carburant de
la reconstruction après la seconde
guerre mondiale mais c'était réservé aux
professionnels de la construction et
puis ensuite avec l'arrivée les chocs
pétroliers arrivant on remplace notre
production d'électricité à base de
pétrole de charbon par du le nucléaire
et donc on se retrouve avec beaucoup de
fioul et on ne sait pas quoi faire de ce
fioul lourd donc on le met dans les
voitures et donc c'est comme ça que le
diesel se développe en france on a été
champions du monde battu justine henin
en 2007 par là pas la norvège et donc on
s'est alors lui dit elle a failli pas
mourir dans de 97 on n'était pas très
loin de repartir dans l'autre sens et
puis finalement ça a été abandonnée et
aujourd'hui on nous jouons encore le
disait le prop alors que des gilles
williams et moi vous n'aurez jamais de
diesel pop ça
east pas avant de passer la parole à
gilles du mois si gilles on va passer la
parole à serge serre ges que vous avez
un avis sur les résultats de
l'utilisation de la vinée critères ou
est ce qu'il ya eu des résultats de la
vie des critères aussi si vous n'êtes
pas capables de répondre à cette
question va poser la question
nicolas gill critère c'est bien que
l'été on sait pas bien quand j'ai un
avis mon avis est que les critères qui
ont conduit à l'attribution de la
vignette critères sont pas du tout les
bombes quels sont les bons parce que je
vais prendre un exemple tout simple vous
prenez les véhicules essence à injection
directe dont je parlais tout à l'heure
ce sont les véhicules qui produisent le
plus de particules or ce sont les
véhicules à qui on a donné la veille la
meilleure vignette critères
c'est peut-être une erreur quelque part
on prend un deuxième exemple les
véhicules diesel euro 6 donc les
derniers qui utilisent des systèmes de
dépollution du no2 soit les soit le
système sr
par réaction catalytique soit le signer
ce système de piège à nox qui est tout à
fait catastrophique puisque les renault
en moyenne produisent en situation
réelle
autour de 12 fois plus de 2 des no 2 que
vous référencer sur quelles études
ça c'est l'étude
transports et environnement du 2
septembre 2010 7
et 16 septembre 2007 donc on a des
données objectives qui nous disent que
ces véhicules sont extraits les diesels
aussi bien avec des systèmes srr et
encore plus avec des pièges à nox sont
des véhicules qui sont très producteurs
de no2 donc très paulo or ces véhicules
euro 6 ans alors on leur a donné quoi la
vignette critère numéro 2 c'est à dire
qu'on les considère comme bon donc il ya
quelque chose qui va pas
été fait pas
ministère du transport allemand qui
montrait qu'en fait quand vous prenez
les véhicules diesel euro 1 est une
norme qui date de 1992 si j'ai pas de
bêtises vous avez déjà tous les 50 euros
2 euros 3 4 5 euros 6 à chaque norme les
émissions en conditions réelles de
conduite des voitures augmentent donc
euro 5 on est au maximum à plus de 1000
microgrammes par mètre cube et à partir
de 06 à recommencer à baisser en
condition réelle même si les normes et
baisse en fait on a un vrai problème
parce que la réglementation des voitures
en europe se fait sur un cycle qui a le
toupet de s'appeler le new york times
michael et qui date de 1973 qui n'est
pas exactement faits récents qui a
changé le heureusement en 1997 pour être
plus réaliste et donc les constructeurs
sans tricher en fait certains on fait ce
qu'on appelle du cercueil beating donc
ils ont optimisé pour être sûr que la
voiture passe la voiture passe les
normes sur le banc mais dès qu'on sort
c'est fois dix fois plus pour certaines
voitures et saas est homologué on vous
dira non n'a pas dû tricher mais
effectivement là le problème c'est que
c'est la commission européenne qui n'a
pas fait son travail de mettre en place
un test qui soit représentatif
alors avec les scandales de volkswagen
là on est avec un test un qui est plus
représentatif qu'il appelle la wlt c est
2 surtout maintenant on va faire des
essais des mesures en conditions réelles
donc là ça va être beaucoup plus
compliqué de de tricher ou d'avoir des
émissions élevées pour le constructeur
ce qui est une bonne nouvelle mais le
problème c'est que ça n'est que sur les
nouvelles voitures et vous avez un parc
en circulation et ça va prendre 15 ans
20 ans a changé toutes ces voitures là
donc on est parti pour sur le dioxyde d
azote
dix ans à ces niveaux là c'est comme en
plus
le la commission européenne a relevé les
tolérances pour le no2 en considérant
que de toute façon aucun véhicule diesel
ne pouvait être conforme
le pas de fatalité à la pollution
donc c'est pas très direct et à la
pollution il faut la combattre il faut
la combattre pas simplement
anne hidalgo la réunion les
constructeurs automobiles alors a dit ok
vous avez triché et on passe à autre
chose comment passage où cela dit
il faut une il faut une mobilité non
polluantes il faut une mobilité non
polluantes il faut des véhicules non
polluants sachant qu'il faut
différencier deux choses la mobilité en
ville et à l'oubli hors des villes et le
problème en france c'est qu'on parle que
d'une mobilité etc de choses qui n'ont
rien à voir en ville moi personnellement
j'ai une voiture une voiture essence pas
trop récente heureusement moi je m'en
sers pas la semaine parce que je vais
prendre le train je prends le vélo après
pour partir en week-end pour partir en
voyage que vous ayez une voiture essence
diesel
quel sort lui
entre guillemets ça n'est pas un
problème puisque dans la station total
entre tours et orléans y'a pas des
niveaux de concentrations de pollution
très élevé le vrai problème c'est la
ville c'est pour ça qu'il faut comme on
l'a très bien fait sur le dé le co2 le
co2 comme on a fait nos amis baisser nos
émissions depuis 20 ans on les a
délocalisé mais les usines en france on
les a mis en europe de l'est en chine et
voilà c'est pareil on l'a fait sur le
co2 faisons le sur les voitures offrant
les voitures on les enlève des villes on
l'aimé ailleurs et si les gens veulent
la garder pour rouler sur l'autoroute
c'est par un problème donc demain la
solution comme le dit gilles soit vous
avez des voitures gpl soit vous avez des
voitures électriques hybrides qui vous
permettent de rouler en électrique en
ville ça s'appelle un véhicule
électrique hybride rechargeable et quand
vous devez faire un trajet et partir en
corse pour pas prendre dix jours pour y
aller en voiture eh bien vous avez un
petit moteur thermique non transfert on
transfère quand même la pollution c'est
à dire que la pollution je vais prendre
exemple bien soudée particules émises
quand sur un véhicule électrique quand
on va recycler les batteries les
émissions dues aux un gros cycle âge des
batteries savent être une pollution qui
va être pire il ya transfert de
pollution mais ça dépend comment
derrière vous faites un l'électricité et
de des batteries je commence par
l'électricité en france le nucléaire a
beaucoup de défauts mais il a au moins
la qualité d'être faiblement et mika et
messi afin de co2 et de particules et
d'oxydés d'azoté ensuite c'est le cas on
enlevait chez le cas c'est moins le
carnaval terme parce que si je prends le
coût d'extraction de l'uranium
le coup d'oeil oui mais le coup est pas
c'est pas des émissions de polluants
être assez limité aujourd'hui s'il faut
sécher sécher tout non mais aussi dans
d'autres pays cela va rentrer et
aujourd'hui c'est qu'une carence grave
s'ils sont en afrique c'est ça
il n'a pas dit si la prise aujourd'hui
40 % d'électricité mondiale vient du
charbon donc la voiture explique c'était
moins dur au charbon donc ça il faut
enlever le charbon non mais ça c'est
très clair déjà il faut enlever le
charbon c'est 40% en allemagne 70 % en
chine donc ça il faut déjà en est
vraiment le truc qui est le truc qui me
gêne profondément c'est que vous avez en
europe
donc ces voitures électriques qui vont
utiliser des batteries la fabrication de
la batterie consomment au moins autant
d'énergie que la fabrication des
voitures donc vraisemblablement on va
aller là produire dans un pays où
l'électricité est entre guillemets
propres pas au charbon qu'est ce qu'on a
fait en europe la première giga factory
européenne qui est de l'entreprise lg
qui me colle va être installé en pologne
dans le pays où la part du charbon est
le plus important au monde avec 98% donc
là on marche complètement sur la chose
une question je rencontrais un petit peu
sur nicolas avant de passer la parole à
serge j'ai vu récemment une petite prise
de bec avec le décodeur ou le des codex
du monde là
concernant la pollution à porter
dû à des particules de charbon émises
par les centrales à charbon et le monde
donc votre postulat cd ça venait
d'allemagne est le postulat du monde
sait ça vient pas d'allemagne on en est
où par rapport à cette petite reprise
donnait là alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'il ya dans les deux polluants
des particules qui qui voyage qui peut
faire plusieurs dizaines de mille
kilomètres
ils les occidentaux qui sont un polluant
locale donc effectivement les particules
dans les sources de particules vous avez
des industries notamment la production
d'énergie avec des centrales à charbon
ou au fioul récemment en france on avait
lavé par chez ville à côté de chez nous
porcheville dans une bonne journée lm
été autant de particules que toutes les
voitures en circulation en ile de france
et c'est il me semble le cas pour le 8
janvier dernier j'avais fait le calcul
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'ils vont
fermer en mars et ils ont même fermé
anticipé
donc oui les on a des échanges avec les
décodeurs et on a un problème sur les
dates en fait puisque e10 qui a pas eu
de charbon et moi je dis qu'on a eu en
fait qui s'est passé c'est que eux se
fie à cette exception française
fidjienne et néo zélandaises quiconque
on décrète si elle la pollution pas
c'est à dire que seul pays au monde où
on a un seuil d'information sur les pm10
c'est la france iles fiji nouvelle
zélande et donc on dit la veille en tout
50 ya pas de pollution ou tu te crois
qu'il ya de la pollution sauf que il
n'ya aucune norme sur les particules
dangereuses et filme donc les pm 2.5 et
c'est là heureusement il ya quand même
un organisme qui s'appelle l'om est ce
qui est l'organisation mondiale de la
santé qui nous dit il ne faut pas
dépasser un niveau plus de trois jours
par an nous à paris pour vous donner
quelques chiffres en 2000 parce que je
m'amuse à des comptes et je suis
probablement le seul en france en 2010
est on a dépassé 40 deux fois en 2016 on
a dépassé 45 fois en 2000 en 2015 on l'a
dépassée de tête 36 2000 2014 d'autres
1,41 et 2013 76 s'améliorer je mets donc
moi ce que je disais c'est que bon
suivant la réglementation de européenne
nous nous ne sommes qu'en nous ne sommes
qu'en pollution massive là et moi je me
place sur le point de vue de l' oms et
donc moi j'ai regardé un jour où nous
avons dépassé ce niveau de l'om est vous
avez regardé comment il ya une semaine
j'ai rencontré nous est racontée j'ai
rencontré hier par ifs je leur ai
demandé ils ont une station à paris qui
à gennevilliers qui permet de faire des
l'analyse de la composition chimique des
particules et donc leur ai demandé de
faire une analyse pour ce jour précis où
nous avions dépassé le niveau que l' oms
recommande de ne pas dépasser plus de
trois heures par an et donc nous avons
bien des particules soufrées qui sont
témoin comme le disait jean et du monde
d'un apport et notamment de centrales à
charbon donc à la fois d'air dû souffrir
mais aussi de nitrate d'ammonium qui a
priori sont venus dans le même nuage et
qui sont émis à priori par la même usine
serge est ce que la mairie de paris
capable de prendre son téléphone et
d'appeler les allemands en disant
écoutez les gars c'est très sympa ou la
pologne
ce qui est important d'avoir en tête
c'est que la pollution paris elle est
avant tout local et on a parlé beaucoup
des diesel mais il faut surtout parler
la plus grande source qui n'est pas le
dl qui n'est pas les ans qui est le
chauffage au bois plus de la moitié des
particules à paris c'est du chauffage au
bois alors pas juste le petit feu de
cheminée et les chaudières au bois et
c'est là le c'est là le problème et
c'est sur dorment plus le problème quand
vous avez une femme politique s'appelle
ségolène royal qui alors qu'on devait
interdire ces feux doigt parce que c'est
la plus grande source de pollution et
bien à faire un rétropédalage pour dire
mais non finalement c'est quand même
sympa les feux de bois alors quand il ya
un pic de pollution effectivement je
crois qu on l'interdît on du genre à
n'en faites attention en tout cas le feu
d'agrément si je dis pas de bêtises mais
mais mais le sujet c'est le chauffage
bois le charbon ça arrive là par exemple
je regardais sur le site de copernicus
un programme européen avec 2 quelle on a
tous payer 9 milliards d'euros c'est nos
impôts et là on peut voir en temps réel
d'où vient les particules samedi
prochain ou dimanche prochain à paris
vous aurez un tiers des particules qui
en allemagne là c'est des choses qui
arrivent mais ça n'est pas le
contributeur principal à la pollution
paris avant de repasser
serge anne hidalgo elle peut appeler en
gueulant il disant goût thé particules
qui viennent de chez toi qu'est-ce qui
n'ont lorrains en votant attention on me
renvoie au temps est évidemment là mais
ce jeu des
équilibres c'est un jeu qui sait qu'il
est bon ce qu'il faut c'est normal c'est
un ensemble de la pollution c'est quoi
c'est que on a une économie impactante
sur le climat sur la négativement
impacté négativement sur le climat sur
la biodiversité et sur les emplois
et sur la santé humaine
il ya même un coup donc l'objectif d'un
homme politique d'une femme politique
quel qu'il soit c'est de dire comment on
invente common un score obligatoirement
une économie du moindre impact sur
l'environnement et sur la santé humaine
l'objectif est là c'est fait comme on
commence on se bat on se bat ce point on
se bagarre il faut absolument inventé
mais je le vois comme ça il économisera
grand guerrier une économie c'est facile
de se moquer
t'as pas dû regarder ce que j'ai fait
dans ma vie un donc
aux bagarres et et se bagarraient je
parlais de la fatalité la pollution mais
cette fatalité d'une économie où on ne
compte pas on parle du nucléaire
effectivement le nucléaire français il
est arrivé sur un coin de table lors de
l'agonie de monsieur pompidou on a
décidé soudain la création de 58
réacteurs nucléaires en france pas
vraiment comme ça que ça s'est décidé
sur un coin de table à matignon avec
avec deux personnes bernard et son père
et
on a bossé avec vous qu'on peut te le
dire en concordantes donc ça s'est
décidé sans son assemblée nationale et
s'enlise dans une loi il ya une j'ai
participé tout simplement
j'avais j'ai arraché à nicolas sarkozy
et à l'audit de la cour des comptes sur
le nucléaire en 2006 est sorti en juin
en janvier 2012 où le monnerat tic
attitré rapport de la cour des comptes
la france ne peut plus payer sur
nucléaire le rapport de la cour des
comptes indiquait qu' on ne comptait pas
et bien beaucoup de choses dans le
nucléaire à l'époque monsieur proglio
disait que ça coûtait pas cher oui mais
tu compte pas les déchets si tu comptes
pas le démantèlement si tu comptes pas
l'assurance etc etc c'est facile de dire
que ça coûte pas cher donc qu'est-ce
qu'on fait qu'est ce qu'on fait à ton
avis qu'est ce qu'on fait j'ai une
petite idée mais ça va pas plaire
il ya un problème qui niveau
malheureusement des jeux revient à la
commission européenne c'est à dire que
c'est eux qui doit fixer les règles et
c'est une bonne chose qu'il ait faite et
c'est grâce à ces règles qu'ils ont
fixées qu'on peut judiciariser donc
attaquer des collectivités locales pour
non respect de la loi qui est le cas à
peu près dans toutes les villes en
europe ça c'est une bonne chose mais ce
qu'il faut c'est qu'au niveau européen
voire au niveau mondial puisque c'est
quelque chose qui pour les particules
voyage c'est à dire qu'on doit tous
faire ça s'il n'y a que la mairie de
paris qui interdit les véhicules diesel
et essence très bien mais on va les
récupérer toutes les villes de la petite
ceinture de la grande ceinture d'orléans
de metz etc on va récupérer les feux de
bois de bordeaux de la vallée de l'arve
donc on doit faire des politiques sur
les sources qui sont diesel chauffage au
bois au niveau européen et que tous les
pays le problème c'est que c'est
impossible dans cette structure
européenne ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
possible vous avez un camp conservateur
majoritaire au niveau de l'europe qui
favorise ceux là qui fabrique qui
favorise simplement au lait aucune
avancée comment se fait-il que
posez vous la question là
bien sûr je suis conseiller de la maire
de paris mais posez vous la question ce
bashing infernal quelques elle vit et
rire et regarder ce qui est dit elle a
créé des embouteillages à la craie et la
pollution la retraitée
elle les sectaires elle était soutenue
au personnel et autoritaire a pas de
voiture électrique qui se balade avec 14
gardes du corps c'est pas vrai c'est ce
qui était marqué je crois bien non parce
que vous écoutez n'importe quoi elle a
une voiture électrique zoé elle prend le
métro elle promet l'ibal marche à pied
elle fait comme quand même comme un
magazine parisien la batterie
brive est d'accord et c'est pour ça que
tu va l'empêcher de
rosemère il ya un maire qui a une petite
voiture accord une recherche qui est un
complot des industriels
parce que les particules des pneus et
des freins ils sont toujours là pourquoi
pas le vélo comme le faisait notre
ministre de la justice pas un sujet est
ce qu'il ya c'est qu'il ya un vrai
bashing est un vrai machine sur elle et
se bashing les éléments de langage sont
toujours les mêmes en moi je bosse avec
elle je ne serai pas avec une femme qui
est logique comme comme on la décrit
elle je dormais ce que je voulais dire
c'est que à partir du moment où il ya
une véritable j'irai attaques contre ce
système là alors elle est très attaqué
ça que je voulais dire donc très
attaquée parce qu'il ya du pognon quand
même à la clé ça ça touche des objectifs
économiques dans tout ça ça tout ça
dérange et là j'en viens à qui la
dérange dans un industriel il y avait
l'écologie mais me loving herman il y
avait monsieur fiterman
à l'époque ministre des transports qui
était
les partis communistes et et qui avait
reçu un coup de téléphone
du patron de peugeot de l'époque dont
j'ai oublié le nom et qui disait c'est
un moment du pot catalytique
voilà ça calvé et donc le pot
catalytique peu jours à retarder
l'avènement du pot catalytique peu de
chez peugeot parce qu'il disait nous on
n'est pas prêt alors que les allemands
eux et étaient prêts et fiterman
fait bien loin et alors et alors que
alors que peugeot était l'un des plus
gros par une de ses filiales un des plus
gros constructeurs de pots catalytiques
qui ont brillé sur la question des
emplois alors moi j'ai fait une
recherche où je me suis intéressé dans
huit villes au monde toutes les mesures
de restriction qui ont été mises en
place pour faire baisser la pollution
donc j'ai regardé londres milan
stockholm oslo shanghai pékin tokyo et
corte et je crois que c'est tout et dans
les cartes et qu'elle lui qu'est ce
qu'on voit dans toutes ces études là que
ce soit en allemagne qui a mis en place
en 2010 que la mairie de paris met en
place l'an prochain sur des vignes est
donc on a un peu de retard en france ce
qui se passe à londres ce qui se passe à
milan et les péages urbains c'est que
forcément tous les commerçants sont là
pour dire mettez pas ça c'est la mort de
nos commerces je vais faire mais là j'ai
bouclé la porte qu'est ce qui s'est
passé concrètement les gens ils ont
laissé leur voiture ils ont plus le
train donc il y aura un report modal
n'ait pas d'impact sur le business pas
d'impact sur les emplois donc oui vous
avez toujours des râleurs et il paraît
qu'en france on en a une proportion un
peu plus élevé qu'ailleurs mais on a vu
qu'en fait vous allez gens ont juste
fait différemment ils se sont organisés
différemment et à paris siège l'a pas
mentionné mais ces péages urbains qu'on
a mis en place dans le début des années
2000 ont fait baisser le trafic de 30%
au wild en mai des péages comme à
londres c'est ça à londres a dit alain
rousset l'histogramme est-ce que ses
ennemis tous les pauvres en dehors de la
halle de la façade et parce que me
lancer vraiment milan c'est l'hyper
centre
alors il faut ça c'est une vraie
question je pense que ce que l'écologie
d'une valeur de riches le problème
aujourd'hui de l'écologie c'est ne pas
exclure les gens les plus pauvres c'est
à dire que quand on dit jeu fait exclure
les voitures les plus sales
malheureusement souvent c'est des gens
les plus pauvres et qui habitent les
plus loin et on peut pas et qu'ils
mangent le plus de populace de pollution
c'est ça il faut leur proposer non parce
que s'ils habitent très loin la campagne
et moins de pollution c'est bon avantage
de paraître dans paris mais ces gens là
il va par les pesticides ab oui mais il
change de polluants aussi pas les mêmes
ce ne sera pas le même consensus de
place mais ce qui est important c'est
que ces gens là il faut leur proposer
une alternative leur dire qu'ils peuvent
pas faire quelque chose très bien mais
il faut qu'ils aient une alternative et
aujourd'hui elles existent elles
n'existaient pas il ya dix ans
d'aujourd'hui par exemple le covoiturage
domicile travail vous avez des
applications qui vous permet de trouver
un covoitureur facilement et de remplir
ses bagnoles parce que le problème de la
voiture en ville c'est que elle est
remplie pour aller au travail par un
virgule une personne d'accord ça c'est
des embouteillages vous mettez deux
personnes et plus de bouchons il ya plus
de bouchons et on demande pas ça coûte
00 euros zéro centime d'argent public
donc il suffit juste de remplir ses
voitures j le dire à quelqu'un par
exemple mais toi tu aimes voiture qui
pollue et bien aujourd'hui parce que
c'est polluer tu vas pas la prendre tu
vas faire du covoiturage avec ton voisin
qui a une voiture qui est un peu plus
récente un peu moins polluantes ou un
peu plus vers hier je sais pas quand
j'ouvre une parenthèse une question
d'internet d'ailleurs c'est pas une
question c'est une remarque est très
très juste il dit on n'a parlé que de
paris pas des restes de la france parce
que les autres villes françaises se
comporte à peu près comme paris ou pas
du tout présente pas les mêmes pollution
lyon vous avez un peu plaisir de ce
trimestre le turbo diesel vous avez
bordeaux avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
bois
pesticides non et vous avez la valley la
vallée de l'arve qu'elle avale et un peu
l'avait l'appelation de la pire enfin la
pire en europe c'est milan mais après
vous allez la vallée de l'arve parce que
là vous avez le trafic des poids lourds
vous avez le chauffage au bois le
tunnelier mondial donné le montant et
l'industrie et l'industrie aussi est
derrière moi j'ai personnellement
contribué justement à organiser du
covoiturage dans cette zone là et donc
dans la vallée de l'arve aujourd'hui les
gens vont pouvoir covoiturer et
descendre ensemble des villages pour
réduire la pollution mais nicolas a
complètement raison sur le covoiturage
c'est parce qu'on pense qu'on a fait un
truc de baba cool et serra et c'est
quelque chose de vraiment de très
important et il faut organiser le
covoiturage
mais prenez l'exemple on vous en
souvenez pas haut mais parce que vous
étiez trop jeune à l'époque
mais lorsqu'il ya eu l'avènement des
premières rues piétonnes
si vous avez entendu ce que ça
représentait les commerçants n'en
voulait pas l'électricité n'est pas
coupable et il y avait beaucoup de
charbon mais la rue les rues piétonnes
serge havet des symboles ou encore la
pause était pieds nus
c'est un scandale et les rues piétonnes
alors qu'aujourd'hui toutes les villes
demandent des rues piétonnes tous les
citoyens devant des rues piétonnes ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a pas quand
même dit mais là ça mais 50 ans il faut
quand même se rappeler qu'au début du
20e siècle toutes les villes quasiment
en france mais même en europe est équipé
d'un tramway un tramway électrique et
tout le monde se bat des soins en
tramway et après la première guerre
mondiale c'était quoi le moindre renfort
ça s'appelait le vélo on a remplacé le
cheval au début avant la prière garde
avec un beau coup de pub d'extrêmement
part du vélo c'est pour ça qu'on appelle
ça une selle de vélo d'ailleurs et puis
après la cwa parce que c'est ça remplace
le cheval d'accord une selle de cheval
de vous passer un vélo ça reste et donc
vous avez après la seconde guerre
mondiale l'avènement de la voiture
individuelle et là qu'est ce qu'on fait
on supprime tous les tramways on les
rase partout en europe de l'ouest pas en
europe de l'est avaient à tallinn le
tramway qui date de plus de 100 ans et
qui est d'ailleurs gratuit pour tout le
monde sait et c'est fantastique et donc
on a mis ça on a pris tous là tout le
transport la sueur des villes apaisé on
a mis plein de bagnols individuelles qui
polluent et maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on
fait combien ça coûte serge combien ça
coûte de mettre les transports gratuits
dont paris et proche banlieue et à
bordeaux ou lyon
à corte ballet l'histoire n'ont pas
franchement moi personnellement je pense
que le transport en commun dans les
villes avec des densités énorme parce
qu'il était pour le mil et l'intensité
de de la ville
je pense qu'il faut travailler la
gratuité pour ça aujourd'hui que anne
hidalgo a
lancé l'initiative du passe navigo
gratuit pour les plus de 65 ans qui est
avec un certain niveau de ressources
c'est sous qui sont les plus vieux qui
ont fait plus de pollution que oui et en
plus ça aussi qu'on discute assuré aussi
qu'ils ont du temps qui choqué beaucoup
des leurs et qui s'occupe beaucoup du
milieu associatif voilà la récolter des
voix
docteur gels en question juste une
question beau gif
autrefois on mesurait la pollution des
transports en kilos de crottin de cheval
au km 10 et nicolas ben on est toujours
à peu près pareil parce que maintenant
mesure des pm10 et on nous dit les pm10
sont à dépasser ce 6 mai - les pm10
sûrement fiche en termes d'effets sur la
santé c'est un marqueur non pertinent
parce que les pm10 on sait très bien
qu'elle passe pas dans la nuit dans la
circle line dans les boisés rien ni la
circulation alors on me dit oui mais les
pm les pm10 à son dans les pm10 ce qui
est faux parce que voit dans les dom et
ruelles ou pas on les voit pas râler les
pmt roy oui mais on les voit pas les
pm10 non les pm10 ne pénètre pas parce
qu au delà de deux microphones douce et
oui ça faisait glomérules ça fait pas ça
ça pénètre pas dans la circulent dans le
dans l'est dans l'arbre aérien et dans
la circulation s'est arrêtée au niveau
des boisés rien supérieur mais mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a gardé les pm10
comme marqueur de la pollution les pm10
et les pc les marqueurs de la pne
d'aider des locomotives à vapeur du
chauffage au charbon des centrales à
charbon tous
ce sont des grosses particules c'est ce
qu'il fait fumer mais on a gardé ce
marqueur pourquoi parce que c'est un
marqueur qui est facile qu'il est facile
de
d'améliorer donges olivier wee d'anjou
avec des lunettes roses ouais c'est
facile de dire on a amélioré la
pollution la diminuer la concentration
de pm10 mais moi je dis moi je m'en
fiche c'est pas moi c'est pas un
marqueur pertinents et pourtant c'est le
marqueur qui au niveau de la commission
européenne reste le marqueur le seul
marqueur réglementaire donc on utilise
un marqueur qui est à peu près au même
niveau que le crottin de cheval en
termes de pertinence et le pour
s'adresser au public parce qu'en fin de
compte c'est le consommateur qui paye
qui l'a fait la pollution
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire un
consommateur pollueurs un organe voiture
consommateurs d'énergie qu'est ce qu'on
peut lui dire par exemple sur les
cancers quand ça se passe d'une fin de
vie combien ça coûte en soins palliatifs
un cancéreux qu'elle quel type de
d'antidouleurs on lui injecte est-ce que
c'est d'uniboard à morphine dans quel
état il termine ses teralys nous
annoncer dont c'est en général il
termine très mal hein mais c'est vrai
c'est pas seulement le cancer vous le
décrire le très mal le voyez le le le
le cas le plus fréquent c'est la bpc au
la broncho-pneumopathie chronique
obstructive c'est essentiellement le
fumeur mais c'est le fumeur plus la
pollution et c'est aussi la pollution
qui responsable de bpce la bpc hausse et
c'est le patient qui qui qui s'essouffle
qui se noie dans c'est clair qu'ils se
noient ou et danser mais et qui ne peut
plus avancer qu'il ne peut plus marcher
moi j'en vois tous les jours qui ce qui
est sous oxygène d'abord pour ce pour se
mouvoir puis en permanence est qui et
qui meurt qui me reste 20 qui s'est noyé
c'est ça oui comme noyé qui sait ce
qu'ils jouent leur un cancer du poumon
ce qui la concerne à ce stade ça tout
dépend tout dépend de type de type 2 de
métastases qu'on aille à des douleurs
claude métastases ou ceux qui sont au
rsa c'est une sas et ça c'est bien ça
c'est gratiné une bonne métastases
osseuses au niveau de la colonne
vertébrale
ça c'est cesser skate meyers as aimé
donc on lire sur ce sont des gens qui
sont ces dates et sous morphine sourds
on termine en légumes quoi mais aussi
l'addition si on prend la pollution plus
la grippe je crois que ça fait mal bah
oui ça fait quinze mille morts par an
ouais
et n'oubliez pas aussi que le les vagues
de froid hivernal les vagues de froid
hivernal sont responsables de
l'associer à la pollution parce que
vague de froid hivernal plus pollution
hivernale
on avait fait des calculs dans le cadre
du concept super de la météorologie on
avait en 40 ambre trouver un peu plus
tôt un peu plus de 300000 morts dont
15000 morts en moyenne par an
gilles eyquem important aujourd'hui on
ne mesure pas la pollution on n'a pas
d'indicateur au niveau européen ce qui
est grave on est incapable de mesurer on
ne mesure pas l'impact sanitaire de la
pollution mesure un truc qui ne veut
rien dire et on dit avec ce truc qui
veut rien dire progresse super on en est
à ce stade là sur la pollution on en est
là faut bien les politiques sont payés à
ne rien faire alors qu'est ce que je
disais au début quand on parle et les
airs par ifs donc donner les moyens il
faut leur des mères qui va leur donner
les moyens nous nos impôts
est ce que ce serait pas les industriels
c'est dire que c'est un peu plus mais
les industriels iront conseil
d'administration d'airparif mais ils
financent très très peu tôt de combien j
assiste un jour à conseil
d'administration il y avait un
représentant des rohan aéroports de
paris qui était en train de dire qu'ils
allaient allait supprimer la subvention
qui devait être de prendre 1000 euros
40000 euros et gg je leur ai dit c'est
un scandale donc quand on est une ong
quand on est en dessous
[Musique]
l'écologie est ce qu'on peut accepter du
fric je partirai finalement est-ce qu'on
peut accepter du fric de celui qu'on est
censé combattre
ça dépend ce qu'on fait avec c'est à
dire ça dépend ce qu'on fait avec comme
moi quand j'étais au wwf quand on
travaillait avec
moi la grande distribution c'est pas mon
histoire c'est parce que j'aime et quand
on a travaillé avec carrefour je peux
vous assurer que sur beaucoup de
domaines beaucoup de sujets et ils ont
fait un travail considérable
s'il n'y a pas d'eau gm en france c'est
en partie grâce à leur fort parce que
soudain à carrefour il y avait une dame
qui te conseil d'administration qui
s'appelle chante chantal jaquet et qui a
fait aussi au conseil d'administration
du wwf et qui a combattu l'avènement des
ogm chez carrefour et carrefour a bloqué
les ogm et un résultat les autres ont
suivi donc pour l'instant il n'y a pas
eu le déferlement des ogm en france et
on peut le dire carrefour a joué ce rôle
là donc et donc sur différents sujets et
pourtant le quart font de l'argent
c'était la grande distribution etc à
partir du moment où sur un sujet vous
avez vous avez une traçabilité l'argent
vous êtes donner cet argent à ça va pour
des missions vous travaillez également
avec des actions correctives avec
l'industriel en question bon ben vous
avez des résultats vous n'avez pas les
résultats et lorsque j'ai travaillé
pendant six ans et demi avec le wwf
propose tous deux directeurs france
pardon au poste de directeur france et
directeur france de 2006 à 2012 ses 5000
6 à 2013 13 voilà combien ça pas le pain
directeur de france les propres je
devais toucher 5600 euros par mois net
est des avantages donc comment on arrive
c'est de la soupe est là parce qu'on est
choisi par un conseil d'administration
ont fait nicolas oui mais je voulais
revenir il ya quand même donc on n'a pas
le bon indicateur mais on acquérir de
l'état qui a demandé de faire des
missions notamment alan c'est ce qui est
l'organisme en france qui s'occupe un
peu de ces questions sanitaires
chronique qui veut dire car je n'ai pas
jeté devant d'âge il
agence nationale de sécurité sanitaire
et environnementale
voilà et donc on fait un rapport qui a
été publié en avril 2017 et qui dit des
donc ce serait pas mal de me virer ce
qui se passe aussi sur les pm 2.5 les
particules plus fines comme le fello ms
on a aujourd'hui un indicateur sur les
plus grosses particules qui comme le
disent ils sont arrêtés au niveau du nez
ne pénètre pas dans le cerveau pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'ira pas mettre ces
réalisateurs sur les particules plus
fines plus dangereuse même si c'est
encore moins de 20 micromètres les plus
fines donc aujourd'hui les profils des
préconisations existe
mais ne se passe rien parce que où est
ce que ça se passe la décision alors je
sais pas si c'est en france aussi c'est
en europe à bruxelles mais si y'a juste
le français qui fait tiens moi je
mettrais bien ça sur les pm 2.5 qu'est
ce qui va faire le polonais qui est en
train de s'étouffer tout seul dans son
dans ces particules de charbon et qui en
envoie une bonne partie à berlin berlin
qui pour le coup ils prennent une bonne
dose de de charbon pleuvait il va être
contre et comme ces d'édition l'unamité
c'est fini une personne pas de décision
se passe rien plus petit dénominateur
commun il se passe rien quand on voit en
inde par exemple des lits des
brumisateurs qui ressemblent à des
canons à neige pour essayer d'aggloméré
de plus grosses particules en l'air ça
vous fait penser à quoi pour vous c'est
cosmétiques pour rassurer les gens ça
c'est réellement quelque chose qu'est ce
que c'est l'un des faux il faut avoir en
tête le diesel si vous voulez c'est une
histoire une particularité européennes
et indiennes mais il n'y a aucun autre
pays dans le monde où les voitures
particulières attention on du diesel que
ce soit en chine pas de voitures
particulières au diesel au japon ou dans
ces pays-là
l'inde cumul le charbon et le diesel
donc la chine ils ont collé charbon mais
il s'intoxiquent bien que le charbon
même si ça va mieux nous on a surtout le
diesel mais on a quelques particules qui
viennent nous rendre visite de temps en
temps au ils ont les deux en même temps
et il va le passer à la voiture
électrique mais à quelle voiture
électrique qui sera fabriquée avec
l'électricité fabriqués au charbon j'ai
fait un petit calcul assez drôle sur
porsche ovine pour cheville je les dis
faisait à peu près autant de particules
aebischer mégawatts elle fait autant de
particules que toutes les voitures en
circulation on prend tous et diesel on
les remplace donc ile-de-france on les
remplace par des voitures électriques eh
bien on a toujours la moitié des
particules puisque pour fabriquer
l'électricité pour cheville qui est
fermé bien heureusement aurait émis la
moitié des particules donc on aurait
juste divisé par deux en remplaçant
toutes les voitures dizaine par des
voitures électriques l'inde à ce vrai
souci là ils ont annoncé la fin des
voitures des ventes de voitures
thermiques en 2030 ce qui est nous en
france et 2040 en angleterre c'est 2040
norvège chez 2025 il tendit 2030 c'est
complètement inconcevable
serge
l'arn la chine les etats unis surtout
l'eau de la chine il afrique
hier qu'aujourd'hui nos voitures les
plus polluantes il ya est entre
guillemets les plus pourris elles
partent en afrique et plus ou les mois
plus pourris donc ça c'est le lie à 1 il
ya un autre et à l'autre qu'on a le
pardon comment il nous est ce que est ce
que
ce qui à votre avis les ong ne sont pas
devenus là
comment comment expliquer ça ne sont pas
devenus de le faire valoir d'une
conduite écologique qui permettrait de
se dédouaner comment oui du greenwashing
est ce que vous imaginez vous j'ai pas
terminée et imaginez oui j'ai toujours
préféré comment imaginez-vous un monde
sans de lg oui mais on peut se
l'imaginer
la question que je me pose c'est est-ce
que le greenwashing
et la pale grey de rire
il faut faire une distinction quand vous
dites ong parce qu'il ya des ong en
france et en fait il faut avoir en tête
que nous sommes un peu plus le latin
notre façon de faire du lobby ce soit à
bruxelles où notre ong c'est une façon
qui est très différente et beaucoup
moins organisé avec beaucoup moins de
moyens que dans les pays anglo saxons
comme l'angleterre ou l'allemagne où je
vous dis en allemagne ils sont très bons
les constructeurs allemands pour faire
du lobby à bruxelles ils imposent ils
font passer ce qu'ils veulent mais leur
zone ng sont aussi extrêmement puissante
puisque c'est elle qui ont mis en place
et 30 procès donc si vous voulez nous on
n'est juste pas organiser ni d'un côté
ni de l'autre nous constructeur c'était
très fort pour faire du lobby au niveau
de l'assemblée etc mais à bruxelles ils
sont nuls alors que les alizés les
allemands arrivent soudés entre eux et
impose tout leur nomme les unes après
les autres donc nous on fait moi
j'appelle ça du lobby un peu la papa on
se prend une bière en tape dans le dos
mais ça se passe pas quand en allemagne
ce soit les constructeurs les ong elles
sont très puissants à bruxelles c'est
flagrant le coût des biens c'est un
grand fossé en face le parlement de tous
les bars autour c'est si vous voulez
faire du renseignement les gains il faut
aller là-bas à l'heure de l'apéro
parenthèse fermée serge revenons à notre
cas où angie parce que quand même le vvf
c'est du costaud ccc 6 milliard de dons
par an c'est ça à l'échelle mondiale oui
on en jeu oublié ses livres qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire avec tout ce pognon
de plus ou de mieux c'est quand que
cette école en dirigeait le wwf-france
moi j'ai pas de doublons les francs soit
70 quand j'ai quitté il y avait 140
personnes
avec 140 personnes vous pouvez
travailler sur le bois illégal
vous pouvez travailler sur la
certification du bois illégal qu'on
pouvait travailler sur un nouvel essai
et vous pouvez imposer contraindre fermé
où on faisait des enquêtes et des
enquêtes forcément vous travaillez avec
la presse et donc de façon à pouvoir
révéler le trafic illégal du bois en
france d'arc à des grosses entreprises
qui est cliquée qui font venir d'afrique
ou d'amérique du sud dubois d'une
manière totalement illégale comment vous
expliquez ou ou d'indonésie et donc
voilà lorsqu'on au chocolat fait par les
petits enfants lorsque lorsqu'on a un on
a travaillé
la première campagne oui au bio dans ma
cantine au moment de l'avènement du film
de jean paul jaud nos enfants nous
accuseront on a été les premiers à ce
moment là à dire que toutes les cantines
scolaires devaient avoir des bio dans
les cantines c'était un travail long
considérable c'est pas facile c'est pas
facile de lorsqu'on on a fait une
enquête une étude sur l'impact qu'avait
le monde des banques et des assurances
les banquiers et les assurances ne
disait
pas plus efficace de faire une politique
écologique qui façonnent un autre d'un
des leurs dans notre banque dans notre
banque on a des
on a des led on n'a lui pas pu être
sifflé et c'est dans vos investissements
alors quand combo financer des
investissements écologiques très bien
des mines de charbon etc donc donc on a
fait une étude cette étude là il a fallu
un an pour la faire ouais vous mettez
plusieurs collaborateurs vous faites
appel à des sommités en tout cas des
personnalités compétentes pour
travailler sur ce sujet là faut les
payer comment quand je travaille là ce
travail là et il est fait honnêtement
qu'on fait vous expliquons taseer
d'annexion ça ce qu'on ne fasse jamais
assez ça oui mais en france les ong
quelles qu'elles soient petites moyennes
grandes font très bien leur travail
comment vous expliquez cette défiance
maintenant de l'opinion publique face
aux ong n'y a là aucune vous vous
trompez les éléphants les sondages les
sondages
non les sondages à l'égard des leçons et
de confiance à l'égard de sujets en
france est excellent c'est vers les ong
que les français ont le plus confiance
non mais quand on voit la confiance des
politiques des journalistes c'est sûr
que vous mieux quatre en tout cas ce
sont des sondages cloud là vous parlez
des politiques et là c'était tout ce
sont les politiques pour lutter contre
une falaise fatalité de la pollution et
forcément on se moque de vous on vous
traite de babak au loroux traite de con
veut revenir dans les grottes cauet que
dirais tu sais
les attaques sont féroces contre les os
que vous préférez vous préférez une ong
à la paul watson ou une nouvelle jeune
nicolas hulot les deux seuls les deux
sont compatibles
le sevrage ce courage de paul watson est
absolument inutile et le pragmatisme
bulot l'est aussi
à force de se moquer de ceux qui luttent
moins 90 de ceux qui ne font rien alors
hulot il a des qualités il a des défauts
mais c'est un homme courageux et
intérieurs glyphosate il faut
l'interdire
docteur bien sur quel type quel type de
polluants le pour vous et le plus
délétères pour l'organisme
vous dites le lui plutonium je dit oui
tout de suite
non parce qu'on est pas trop exposer au
plutonium pour l'instant
le nord ne nous a encore rien envoyé à
7h et a7 segré fessenheim les en fait le
le le polluant le pollueur qui nous qui
nous inquiète le plus c'est c'est
l'effet cocktail de la pollution
atmosphérique c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que l' oms a classé en 2013 la pollution
atmosphérique comme cancérogène certain
parce que vous avez des effets cocktail
entre eux les polluants gazeux qui sont
des irritants des voies aériennes les
particules qui sont des irritants des
voies aériennes mais qui se sont aussi
en quelque sorte des adjuvants des
pollens qui sont des allergènes vous
avez
l'effet de certaines particules et qui
contiennent des achats pelles effet
cancérogène de ces particules vous avez
à ça vous allez ajouter à ça
d'autres d'autres polluants comme le
radon le radon est un gaz radioactif
dont qin que nous que nous respirons
dans nos maisons nous allons vous allez
avoir le formaldéhyde le formaldéhyde
dans la terre de feu
que vous allez
inhalé souvent dans l'est dans les
maisons où ils bazaine aussi parce que
ça provient de votre environnement
intérieur de vous de vos meubles de vaud
de vaud moquette donc le polluant qui
nous préoccupe le plus c'est cet effet
cocktail de tous les polluants et pas
l'un ou l'autre ou l'un plus que l'autre
forcément parce que ils ont les
respirent tous ensemble et tous les
jours et c'est ça qu'il faut considérer
et pas dire moi je m'intéresse aux pm10
parce que et moi je réponds les pm10 je
m'en fous ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce
cocktail de polluants et ce qui
m'intéresse de plus en plus ce sont des
particules de plus en plus fine que nous
respirons parce qu'en fait on est passé
de particules
micrométrique les pm10 à des particules
nanométriques c'est à dire qu'on a
divisé les diamètres par un facteur 1000
est ce que nous respirons maintenant les
particules des moteurs essence moderne
c'est du 80 nanomètres les particules
des moteurs diesel moderne c'est du 100
nanomètres et au moins on parle de de
pm10 mais c'est un non sens on parle de
quelque chose qui n'a rien à voir avec
la pollution que nous respirons
effectivement on agite le chiffon on
arrive à la fin de notre interview je
vais redonner la parole aux nicolas et
je vais tout de suite vous donner la
parole après nicolas pour la dernière
question la dernière question c'est même
pas une question s'est laissé un conseil
pour les jeunes générations des
solutions ce que vous voulez quelque
chose d'impérissables qui va rester sur
internet nicolas millions alors moi je
veux juste revenir sur les rideaux angie
rapidement les ong le rôle prépondérant
si aujourd'hui on a eu ce scandale et ce
qui se passe sur le 10e c'est grâce aux
orange et c'est grâce à l' ong a ici
city aux états unis parce que ce
problème je le rappelle la commission le
commissaire européen était au courant
depuis 2012
2012 ça a été couvert ça a été couvert
et l'histoire que j'ai lu à vérifier
c'est comme les a touchés c'est que des
fonctionnaires de la commission
en ayant ras-le-bol que ce soient
couverts sont allés aux états unis alors
une fois de plus c'est à vérifier pour
dire tiens mais vous lirez pas regarder
cette voiture-là voir comment ça
fonctionne et c est donc c'est quand
même dingue que ce scandale qui est
européenne parce qu'il n'ya pas de
diesel états unis soit découvert aux
états unis et deux chiffres que je vais
vous donner une fois plus la fois le
vérifier parce que je leur de grandeur
volkswagen triche en europe aux états
unis quelle est la punition aux états
unis de tête c'est je pense que c'est 10
ou 20 milliards de dollars d'amendé
quelle est la punition en europe 0 donc
les gens qui trichent ne sont pas punis
en europe c'est vrai pour la pollution
c'est vrai pour un certain de choses
tant que vous ne punissez pas vous
n'êtes pas renvoyer les enfants vous ne
puissiez jamais eh ben ils feront
n'importe quoi tant qu'ils le veulent et
ce sera entre guillemets bordel infligé
une amende de 20 milliards en ourdou
ferme
écoutez je sais pas comment ça peut se
passer mais c'était à la hauteur de ce
qu'ils ont triché et renault n'a pas
triché comme volkswagen eux ils ont
délibérément aux états unis qu'il est le
pays où il n'ya pas de diesel il faut
rappeler que la volkswagen jetta a été
la voiture verte de l'année je crois en
2008 2009 2012 ça c'est un scandale ils
ont ils ont la décence de rendre leurs
prix pour les quartiers mais donc ils
ont quand même juste tricher
délibérément ce qu'ils étaient et ça se
faisait depuis attention ils ont
commencé à faire ça depuis les années 90
puis travaillé dessus avec audi enfin je
veux dire ça fait 16 ans c'était
incroyable ils ont été obligés de
racheter toutes les voitures ils ont
racheté toutes les voitures
les voitures un conseil pour les jeunes
générations peut-être que vous voulez
rajouter un dernier vous nous avant de
laisser un conseil
un conseil est justement qu'on soit en
vo par wayne chez
moi j'aime bien une phrase de teilhard
de chardin qui dit pour s'unir il faut
savoir différents or nous avons besoin
d'unité d'union
avec toi différence avec y compris nos
divergences pour pouvoir lutter contre
cette fatalité d'un monde qui détruit je
le rappelle l'environnement le climat et
les emplois une super économie ça c'est
un génération merci
mon père
a beaucoup lutté contre l'exploitation
et des hommes et des femmes et je
pourrais je pourrais lui dire que sa
cause de nuit non non et génération à
toi oui mais monfils pourra dire mes
enfants pourront dire aussi que je suis
responsable
je tente de faire ma part
bons conseils je m'attendais à une
phrase de pascal poli mais bon ça c'est
[Rires]
gilles attend s'intéresse à la pollution
tout le monde s'intéresse à la pollution
du voisin
il faut aussi s'intéresser à sa propre
pollution cesser son comportement la
pollution la pollution c'est la
pollution de chacun c'est l'addition de
la pollution de chacun et il faut pas se
dire moi je moi je peux lui pas parce
que mon marchand de voitures m'a dit que
la voiture que j'ai achetés ne pollue
pas il faut se poser les vraies
questions et se dire pourquoi est-ce-que
on a une pollution qui est à la fois
d'origine individuel d'origine deux
industriels qui est d'origine de fans de
multiples origines mais se dire quelle
est ma part dans la pollution moi j'ai
répondu à cette question il ya déjà
vingt ans parce que j'étais au conseil
national de l'air j'ai dit dorénavant je
roulerai dans des voitures à gaz et je
ferai du covoiturage
effectivement on pense toujours que
c'est aux autres de faire un effort non
c'est d'abord soi même on regarde ses
déplacements comment on va tous les
jours au travail comment on peut
l'améliorer comment on peut baisser
notre empreinte de pollution et après si
on a déjà fait pour soi même on peut en
parler autour de soi partager des bonnes
idées aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus
facile qu'avant de faire du covoiturage
avant on faisait de l'auto-stop on sait
pas qui c'était on avait peur de se
faire agresser aujourd'hui le mec est
noté il a des étoiles souvent c'est
notre collègue c'est vraiment beaucoup
plus simple donc les solutions existent
on a même des solutions on n'a pas parlé
du vélo mais le vélo en ville le vélo
électrique ça suffit en transport
individuel ça s'appelle un vélo
électrique moi ce que je dis souvent ces
jeux on ne peut plus se permettre de
circuler tout seul en voiture à pétrole
en ville ça ça doit être bannie et ça va
l'être de toute façon donc commençons à
nous organiser différemment et faisons
le d'abord nous et après encourageant
les autres à le faire parce que tout
seul effectivement ça changera pas grand
chose qu'ils feront remarquer si je
parlais d'unités tout à l'heure c'est
parce que souvent nous citoyens ou
souvent associé à des coûts élevés on
n'a pas chacun sa petite chapelle on a
pas séparés chez les hackers mais je
suis les corses mais c'est plus d'écho
chez eux mais
pas tout à fait vrai mais
l'histoire c'est que lorsqu'on s'attaque
à des lobbys en face ils sont très
organisés ils peuvent se détester parce
qu'ils ont et ils ont ils sont que s'ils
sont très solides pour chanson égocentré
mais lorsqu'ils sont attaqués ils
forment le carré et là c'est très très
difficile de pouvoir attaquer nous on
savait avec les uns les autres et c'est
pas normal je crois que
7,7 l'astronomie la raison et je crois
aussi qu'il faut c'est pour ça que je
dis et pour finir il faut savoir
d'édifier différent parce qu'on est
différent on parle pas de la même
manière
gilles un savoir faire nicolas aussi
j'en ai un autre mais les trois ensemble
c'est une force
avec deux différences avec nos
différences et donc c'est vraiment un
conseil que je donne à nos jeunes qui
nous écoutent il faut une cohérence
c'est pas simplement une idée on va pas
devenir des maoïstes pour attaquer pour
faire le grand chemin non le long chemin
non non non il faut avoir l'intelligence
comment on va pouvoir enrayer un monde
qui détruit des générations futures
parce qu'il a la prenez le métro qui
sont internet est telle qu'on y va telle
qu'on y va on va entre un monde entre
mad max et l'abbé pierre je je je marche
à pied je prends le métro
vélib autolib sa réponse a répondu à la
question messieurs merci et à bientôt
sur notre chaîne merci vous êtes
dépassés j'espère que ça a permis à la
communauté de s'informer un peu plus sur
ce sujet qui est très grave pour nous
pour les générations futures merci bien
coupé qui
[Musique]